today on the matt walsh show the
american booksellers association
apologizes for a violent incident where
they promoted a book that leftists don't
like we'll talk about this story and
more broadly about the idea that words
books and opinions can be violent what
does that even mean also five headlines
including the surgeon general's pledge
to start putting warning labels on
speech it doesn't like the white house
says that it's working with facebook
working with facebook to tamp down
misinformation pope francis continues
his war against conservative catholics
and leaked audio proves that sharon
osborne was indeed set up and framed as
a racist before being kicked off her
talk show and our daily cancellation
we'll talk about the new efforts to
combat the negative stereotypes of
sharks all of that and more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
before we get going today i want to tell
you about rockauto.com why am i always
telling you about rockauto.com well
because i'm trying to help you out okay
this is this is all about you and my
deep concern for each and every one of
you
if you're having car trouble if you need
any or if you need any kind of auto part
for any reason whatsoever
you can waste time and money by going to
the auto parts store you can do that but
i don't want you i don't want you to do
that to yourself you can just go to
rockauto.com instead rockauto.com you
know they always offer the lowest prices
possible
they're not going to change the prices
and the great thing is if you see the
price on rockauto.com whatever it is
there you don't have to worry about
shopping around finding a different
price uh comparing and contrasting you
know it's the best price available
and uh they're a family business they've
been doing this online for 20 years you
can go to rockauto.com to shop for auto
and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique it's
extensive but it's also easy to navigate
and easy to find what you want so go
right now to rockauto.com see all the
parts available for your car truck and
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box i know that we sent you
as we begin here i want to mention that
it's friday and the best thing about
friday is that friday is the day when my
newsletter is sent out but if you
haven't signed up for my newsletter yet
then you're missing out and your friday
is incomplete just as your very life and
existence are incomplete even pointless
i would say if you're not receiving my
newsletter you can remedy that now by
going to mattwalchreport.com
in the matt walsh report you'll find of
course information insight unmatched
wisdom and also violence because as
we've learned words and ideas are
violence which brings us to
the american bookseller association a
trade organization that works with
booksellers in the country hence the
name and recently they sent out what
they call their white box mailing which
sounds a little racist to me frankly to
750 book stores one of the the titles in
that package was abigail schreyer's
excellent book called irreversible
damage the transgender craze seducing
our daughters if you want to hear more
about that book you can check out my
interview with schreier on my youtube
channel but
the mere site of this book was
apparently quite traumatizing to some of
the people who received it
and that led to backlash and that led to
the american bookstore association
uh releasing one of the most pitiful
embarrassing
self-flagellating groveling apologies we
have yet seen
yesterday afternoon they put this one
they put this out on twitter this is
what they said
quote an anti-trans book was included in
our july mailing to members this is a
serious violent incident that goes
against aba's policies values and
everything we believe and support it is
inexcusable we apologize to our trans
members and to the trans community for
this terrible incident and the pain we
caused them we also apologize to the
lgbtqia plus community at large and to
our book selling community apologies are
not enough we've begun addressing this
today and are committed to engaging in
the critical dialogue needed to inform
concrete steps to address the harm we
caused
personally i'm offended because
in their statement they did not include
the phrase lived experience
and they also didn't include the phrase
do the work
and we know that in these kinds of
statements those two phrases are
required
you know it's an interesting thing
though about the
lgbtqia plus community
we're told that they're strong and proud
and brave and stunning and yet we're
also told that they're so fragile as to
be harmed by merely looking at the cover
of a book they don't like
so which is it is it strong and brave
and proud
or fragile prone to collapsing into
puddles of tears at the site of a of a
book
it's kind of got to be one of the other
right
now the next part of the story is so
predictable that you can fill in the
blanks yourself
i'll ask you do you think that the aba
was forgiven for this grave offense
was the apology accepted
did the groveling and self-abasement
achieve whatever end they had in mind
of course not publishers weekly reports
quote booksellers said the apology fell
short calling out the organization's use
of the passive voice in the opening
sentence they also demanded greater
transparency about how the
decision to include the book was
initially made and called for
demonstrable steps to restore trust with
trans book workers
and authors
some called on the aba to offer
promotions for trans authors books at no
cost
just straight up extortion
you want our feelings to not be heard
anymore uh just uh give us promotions at
no cost
that'll that'll heal our emotional
wounds
and uh also 500 000 in unmarked bills
okay uh anyway back to the statement
says aba diversity equity and inclusion
committee member
uh louis korea who works as a bookseller
at avid book shops in athens georgia was
first made aware of the issue when
fellow booksellers emailed him
morrissey's tweet korea identifies as a
queer latino and fat body person
oh my gosh
identifies as a fat bodied person
well you either have a fat body or you
don't
but what's the point of saying that
you're either a man or you're not right
uh he said he thought the apology was
flawed
i'm disappointed with the use of the
passive language at the beginning of the
statement and the shift in blame
they really should have said that we
included this book
korea said
so the apology was not enough
so what do they do apology is not enough
what do you do now
well you keep apologizing
more from publishers weekly they say in
an email late wednesday aba ceo allison
hill
issued an additional statement to
booksellers she apologized not only for
the promotion of schreier's book but
also for a racist incident last week in
which the organization featured blackout
by um danielle clayton tiffany d jackson
nick stone angie thompson ashley
woodfolk and nicola yoon on its indie
next next
best-seller list but included in
incorrect cover image
instead of using the actual cover the
aba used a book cover by an author who
hill described as quote a different
black author a right-wing extremist
editor's note here the right-wing
extremist is our very own candace owens
who also wrote a book called blackout
apparently it's racist to promote
candace owens who you may have noticed
is black
but the apology said
we traumatized and endangered members of
the trans community we erased black
authors conflated black authors and put
the authors in danger through a forced
association
we further marginalized communities that
we want to support hill wrote she
reiterated that the organization will
take steps to address both instances in
the coming weeks adding that quote there
is nothing that i can say that will make
this right this should not have happened
i want to apologize for both of these
harms and for the pain that aba caused
but i know only action matters these
were egregious harmful acts that caused
pain and violence
one negligent irresponsible and racist
the other negligent irresponsible and
transphobic
she then took out a knife and committed
harry carey on the spot
perhaps not literally but figuratively
at least and even if she had done it
literally the left still would not have
been satisfied they would have said that
like that form of suicide isn't painful
enough enough she should have done
something more progressive like throw
herself into a wood chipper
their whole gig the whole point is to be
offended and victimized and traumatized
all the time always by everything
anything you do to relieve the trauma
will only further it
but that won't stop the gutless
spineless blobfish among us from trying
now as for the book itself
you will notice
that none of the people complaining
about it
have bothered bothered to articulate any
sort of criticism about the content of
the book itself
what is your problem exactly with the
book what what is what's wrong about it
what does it get wrong
well they can't say that's because the
book itself is well researched balanced
almost entirely non-polemical and it
focuses specifically on the explosion of
trans identification among adolescent
girls who are so often pushed along the
path to full medical transition without
anyone stopping to even consider why
else a young girl might feel dysphoric
about her body
nor do they worry about any of the
long-term effects that they are
consigning her too
in other words the book from a content
perspective is unassailable
it is unassailable factually
scientifically and morally
which is why they assail it in general
terms on an emotional level based on the
title and the cover
but the most interesting and disturbing
thing about this story is the use of the
word violent i think
um aba called the mailing of a book of
the book a violent incident and they
kept using you know
violence harm
pain all these kinds of words
i can see how mailing something might be
violent if you know ted kaczynski is the
guy setting the package but how can a
book be violent
how can words and ideas be violent
i think the answer refers us back to the
opening of the show yesterday when we
talked about the left's intense
obsessive nearly exclusive focus on the
self
specifically on how on how the self
feels about itself
according to the leftist religion
nothing matters so much as that
your self-perception
is more important even than your own
physical health which is why people
mutilate their physical bodies in order
to conform to their self-perception
if there's a if there's a a lack of
correlation if there's a
if there's an incongruity between the
self-perception uh the mind the emotions
and the physical body
rather than try to conform the
self-perception to the physical body
they go the other way around
literally chopping pieces off of the
body in order to make it conform with
the self-perception
everything must be enslaved subjugated
by the self's perception of itself
everything is in service to that
perception everything and everyone must
affirm that perception
and the problem is that self-perception
is a fragile fickle ever-changing thing
emotions change how you feel about
yourself changes how you see yourself
changes
which means that the world's affirmation
must be unyielding
and unconditional
this is what's meant by violence
this is how speech and opinions and
ideas become violent
they're violent because an opposing idea
an argument a fact
presented might undermine or cause you
to question your self-perception or at
the very least it may fail to
enthusiastically affirm that perception
which is to do it harm which is violence
everything
that matters to a leftist
is happening in the realm of emotions
and thoughts in the ego
actual reality is irrelevant to them and
so when you hurt their feelings or cause
them to think uncomfortable thoughts you
have hurt them in the way that matters
most to them you have committed violence
that's where this is coming from
which is not to defend it i mean this is
all quite insane
deeply disordered not a way for any
human to live
it's a recipe for confusion and despair
and a life wasted trapped in your own
ego looking in the mirror smelling your
own farts
but this is the life that a leftist
leads
and it's the life he wishes for you and
especially for your children
to join him in his psychosis
and that is an infide invitation that i
think we should all certainly
decline
now let's get to our five headlines
i'm always very excited to tell you
about moink because with moink it's all
about the meat in fact i got uh my
latest monk shipment yesterday i came
home from work and i walked in the door
holding this big box of meat
and uh you know you could say that i was
literally bringing home the bacon so
uh
get it because
there's bacon in the box anyway um moint
delivers grass-fed and grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and wild-caught alaskan salmon direct to
your door helping family farms become
financially independent outside of big
agriculture their animals are raised
outdoors their fish swim wild in the
ocean and moink meat is free of
antibiotics hormones sugar any of that
junk you don't want it's just it's just
the meat and it's absolutely delicious
you can sign up at mointbox.com walsh to
get a year of bacon for free and then
pick what meats you want
delivered with your first box you can
change what you get each month and
cancel anytime it's like christmas when
you get your meat shipment it is a meat
christmas
every month and you want to give
yourself that gift so join the movement
today go to moicbox.com walsh right now
and listeners to this show will get free
bacon for a year that's one year of the
best bacon you'll ever taste but for a
limited time spelled m o i n k box.com
walsh that's monkbox.com walsh
all right you know uh
it is interesting talk about perceptions
um
it's interesting as uh you know to see
how your priorities
change
your your perceptions
in different phases of your life
your desires
and so i'm in a phase of my life right
now um raising a bunch of young children
where i really appreciate loud and
sort of technically unpleasant dining
experiences
and people have had who have who don't
have young children
probably can't
understand or appreciate
the comfort that we as parents of young
children take when we walk in this is
why we love you know chain restaurants
you got like a place like texas
roadhouse you go in there
and they're i mean it's it's loud it's
like there's loud music and everyone's
being loud and they're talking to each
other at a decibel they could drown out
a jet engine and they're throwing trash
on the floor i mean they give you a
bucket of peanuts and you just toss the
shells on the floor there's trash
everywhere and it's and it's it's cheap
and they give you crayons and there's a
and there's a kid's menu um and in in a
certain way it's deeply unpleasant but
also it's great because you have kids as
a low pressure low anxiety situation and
you know that you're around your own
people you're with your kind and you
don't have to worry about anything
and at a minimum i mean your table just
has to be less obnoxious than the most
obnoxious table in the building and so
again very low pressure
but things can go horribly awry when you
miscalculate
and this is something again if you're
not a parent if you don't have young
kids you might not understand that the
the
the
just anxiety
and panic attack that ensues when you
miscalculate
and you go into a restaurant that's way
quieter and classier than you thought so
this happened up to my
to my wife and i a few days ago
uh we were driving we stopped in this
restaurant
and based on my brief preliminary
investigation it seemed like a
family-friendly place and by family
friendly you know i mean loud dirty
obnoxious and cheap
and i walk in and immediately i'm i'm
suspicious because we go up to the
hostess stand and there are no crayons
and no children's menu and that should
have been the clue right there to turn
around and walk out but we didn't rookie
mistake they lead us back to our table
the whole
building it's
quiet you know no one is making a sound
and there's a little bit of music on the
speaker but they take us to the quietest
place in the quiet restaurant with all
these quiet childless couples sitting
there having their nice meals and at a
place where you couldn't even hear the
faint music it was just dead quiet now
people sitting at their tables weren't
even talking to each other they were
just sitting there in stone silence it
was like being at a wake or a funeral or
something and then we sit down and every
single noise
that our kids make just reverberates
the one-year-old throws her apple juice
on the ground and then starts crying
because the apple juice
that she threw on the ground is now on
the ground
and everyone can hear it everyone can
hear every single
noise
everyone you know they all they do is we
just get the icy glares the entire meal
and by the way i get it
if you're at a restaurant buy without
any kids someone walks in with kids i i
get it you don't have to you don't have
to stare i understand how you feel
moral of the story
if you walk into a restaurant with your
kids and there are no crayons and no
children's menu turn around it's not
worth it that's the moral of the story
all right um
so some news from 1984 first the surgeon
general
said that they're going to start putting
you know you know certain general
warnings and you see them on
cigarette boxes of cigarettes
usually it's associated with things that
you eat and
you know things that could cause
physical harm to you
but now they're going to start putting
certain general warnings
on speech so staying on this theme of
speech causing physical harm or some
sort of harm speech being violent
that's the plan now and here is the
surgeon general
explaining
today
i issued a surgeon general's advisory
on the dangers of health misinformation
surgeon general advisories are reserved
for urgent public health threats
and while those threats have often been
related to what we eat drink and smoke
today we live in a world where
misinformation poses an imminent and
insidious threat to our nation's health
health misinformation is false
inaccurate or misleading information
about health according to the best
evidence at the time
and while it often appears innocuous on
social media apps on retail sites or
search engines the truth is that
misinformation takes away our freedom to
make informed decisions about our health
and the health of our loved ones
during the coven 19 pandemic health
misinformation has led people to resist
wearing masks in high risk settings
it's led them to turn down proven
treatments and to choose not to get
vaccinated
this has led to avoidable illnesses in
depth
simply put health information has cost
us lives
misinformation takes away our freedom
if that's not an orwellian statement i
mean that is that is
i'd have to read the book again it
sounds like something that would
actually be in the book itself
so misinformation takes away our freedom
in other words you know
a statement
that you don't like takes away your
freedom
free so that's free speech free speech
takes away our freedom
free speech undermines our freedom is
what's being claimed here i thought it
was really fascinating that that he
specifically mentions this is the the
surgeon general saying that uh well
misinformation about masks
made people reluctant to wear masks
okay well
yeah do you know who
at the beginning of the beginning of the
pandemic was telling people not to wear
masks the surgeon general
sent out a tweet the surgeon general's
office not the same guy
but certain general's office sent out a
tweet back in whatever was march of last
year
saying stop wearing masks in all caps
public health officials dr fauci said
don't wear a mask now they say wear the
mask
[Music]
but the point is
and i think they were right the first
time by the way
but the point is that when
on this
on this basis here
when the surgeon general had said
a year ago don't wear the mask
if you said no i think you should wear a
mask you would have been that would have
been tagged as misinformation
and now they say wear the mask and you
say no you know what i think you were
right the first time now that's
misinformation
opposing views both are misinformation
because what is misinformation it's not
we don't label things or they're not
labeling things misinformation based on
its relation to truth
it's misinformation based on its
relation to the claims that they are
making
and that is the very obvious problem
with the government's campaign against
misinformation it's the problem with
labeling misinformation some sort of
public health threat
many problems with it once again
equating speech with violence which is a
direct attack on the very concept of
free speech
but the other issue is that what do they
consider misinformation
they have made themselves the scientific
authority
and to trust the science is to trust
them
conflating the two it's exactly the same
if you don't trust them then you don't
trust the science
yeah the thing about vaccines
um sure there can be misinformation
claims that are made about vaccines on
either side of the debate that are
simply wrong sure that exists
but much of what is labeled
vaccine
misinformation is really a matter of
priority
right it's it's someone expressing their
priority
the risk level that they're comfortable
with
many of the people who have not gotten a
vaccine
it's because if you listen to what
they're saying
okay just
most of the average people haven't got
it
you actually listen to what they're
saying
what they're saying is um
you know i
i'm worried about potential side effects
i'm worried about we don't know about
the long term and i'm i'm judging this
base and then i'm also comparing that to
the threat posed to me
uh in my own demographic group
by covid and i'm making a judgment and
that's why i don't want to get the
vaccine
now you could disagree with that
decision
you could say that you think it's a
foolish decision or whatever that's
that's your own
personal uh opinion based on your own
priorities
but that's what we're talking about so
how can that be misinformation
it's just someone weighing risks
balancing everything out and saying you
know here's here's how here's how it all
shakes out for me personally
here's the risk level that i'm
comfortable with
here are the risks that i'm risks that
i'm worried about and then these risks
over here i'm not as worried about
that's i don't how can that even be
misinformation it's it is a matter of
personal priority that's it
um meanwhile jen saki kind of on the
same theme here
dropped this bomb rather casually let's
listen
this is a big issue of misinformation
specifically on the pandemic in terms of
actions alex that
we have taken or we're working to take i
should say from the federal government
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office we're flagging
problematic posts for facebook uh that
spread this information we're working
with doctors and medical professionals
to connect uh two connected medical
experts with popular with popular who
are popular with their audiences with uh
with accurate information and boost
trusted content so we're helping get
trusted content out there
that's nice of them
they're flagging misinformation for
facebook
really really helpful they're
trying to help out
uh so this is something to keep in mind
and i like how she she mentions that
like it's no big deal
um
nothing controversial about it oh yeah
we're doing this with facebook
we're we are telling as as a you know as
the white house as a political entity
we're telling facebook
what qualifies as misinformation or
disinformation
and she says that like it's no big deal
like it's it's obvious that they would
be doing that
and actually it is kind of obvious that
they would be doing that that doesn't
make it okay though but it's something
to keep in mind when you hear
about um how facebook is nothing but a
private company
that's all
no different from the uh from the small
town baker and so if you think that the
small town baker should be able to bake
whatever cake he wants
and then facebook should be able to do
whatever they want
of course the absurdity of that argument
is that the people who make it don't
think the baker should be able to bake
whatever cake he wants
they think that the
decisions made by a baker in colorado
are more significant
and
carry with them a deeper national and
global consequence
than the decisions made by
these multi-billion dollar corporations
that control the way that people
communicate and the ideas that are
allowed to be communicated
that that's that's the the utter
absurdity of it
the same people who make that comparison
oh you're the one who said they bake
whatever the cake they want yeah no you
see
the conflict here
the irrationality it's on your end
because it's very easy for me to explain
how facebook is different from a baker
it it literally it harms no one if a
baker just bakes whatever cake he wants
um
doesn't want to bake a gay wedding cake
uh or or he'll say you sell you a cake
but he's not gonna cut that's really
what the issue was right
it's not even we're refusing service to
gay couples it's just
we're not going to make a customized
cake for this particular event you can
still buy a cake from us and customize
it yourself or you can go to any of the
dozens of other bakeries around and get
the cake that you want
now in that scenario it harms no one
there there is no national consequence
whatsoever
what happens when
these multi-billion dollar big tech
companies
that control the way that billions of
people communicate
what happens when they
have political bias ideological bias
i would say the consequences are quite a
bit more severe
all right let's move on here nicole
hannah jones of 1619 and uh just sort of
general race-baiting fame
back a couple of years ago she was
talking about cuba
in a podcast uh and you may have noticed
that i've talked about the cuba thing a
little bit on the show
i haven't spent a lot of time on it
um and not because it's not important
part of it is just
my focus is always on issues that are
happening right here in america that
affect you know american families that
that's that's my focus that's always
been the focus of the show
and i bring that up because i've been
asked actually by several people why
haven't i talked about the cuba thing
more and it's uh that's that's one of
them i just i don't talk about
international issues all that much it's
not where my focus is it's certainly not
where my if i have any expertise at all
it's not there
but i also have to confess
i get a little annoyed
in some ways
to see
all of these republics especially a lot
of elected republicans
coming out very strongly against
the communist cuban government
you know in a in a very direct
way
they're con they're coming out against
it aggressively
aggressively opposing
communism in the cuban government
and that's fine i i agree with them that
the communist cuban government is bad
fully agree
but then i noticed that a lot of these
same republicans
they're not nearly as aggressive or
outspoken
about the communist takeover of our own
country because to me
that is the bigger problem
that's what i'm worried about
so that's that's you know my thinking
there but
there are still some relevant issues to
discuss discussed surrounding that and
so this brings us back to nicole hannah
jones uh she
was
uh on a podcast back in a couple years
ago
and the subject of cuba came up and this
is what you said about cuba back then
is there are there candidates right now
or even just places that you think have
a
viable and sufficiently um ambitious
integration agenda and if so what what
is it
[Laughter]
that laughs at a lot right yeah i mean
one let me just um
i i'm definitely not an expert on uh
race relations internationally um
and
it's also hard to
look at countries that didn't
have you know large institutions of
slavery and compare them to united
states
the answer is probably going to be
surprising that i'm going to give which
is
if you want to see the most equal uh
multiracial
uh it's not a democracy
most equal multiracial country in our
hemisphere it would be cuba
cuba has the least inequality between
black and white people
uh uh any place really in the hemisphere
that uh i mean the caribbean
most of the caribbean it's it's hard to
count because the white population in a
lot of those countries is very very
small their country's run by black folks
but
in places that are truly
at least biracial countries cuba
actually has the least inequality
and that's largely due to socialism
which i'm sure no one wants to hear
now i do want to hear this in fact and
i'm glad that she
brought that up
she's now that this clip has resurfaced
uh she's being criticized for that again
claiming that cuba has
the most equality cuba has more equality
than the united states
but she's right
she is absolutely right
uh the
at least the fundamental point she's
making there
is that there's more equality in cuba
than there is here
true
um
because almost everyone is impoverished
and oppressed in cuba
so that's what we mean
when everybody is poor and miserable and
oppressed there's equality we are we are
all equal
uh down here in in the gutter with this
boot on our neck
right
so equality in that sense she is right
about that
you're gonna find that that's that's one
of the reasons why
um
i don't i don't talk about equality as
much quality is not a priority for me
it's not a value
like a lot of people claim to think it
is for them
you know when we talk about the kind of
equality we should strive for
we we mean equality or we should mean
equality in a highly qualified way
what what's the kind of equality that we
should have in this country i'll tell
you what it is
this is it
equality under the law
and all that means is that no one should
get any special favors everyone should
be
treated the same should get the same
amount of justice
the laws should be the same for
everybody
maybe just simply put it that way the
laws should be the same for everybody no
matter who you are what your demographic
is how much money you have or don't have
that's the way it should be
that's oftentimes not the way it really
works here
but that's the equality we should be
striving for in an ideal scenario that
should be the goal and that's it
same loss for everyone that's it that's
all of the equality that we should want
that's all the equality we should be
talking about
because equality in any other
context
is
in practice a horrific thing
the most equal countries when
we talk about equality of outcome
equality in terms of of the way people
live
the success that they have or don't have
if you want equality there
well you're going to find that kind of
equality in places like cuba in places
like north korea
where most people except for the top of
the top the elites
a relatively small group almost everyone
else is impoverished and oppressed
that's where you find equality
in a country with true freedom
there's no equality to be found anywhere
except for in the law
but everywhere everywhere else because
you have freedom
outcomes will
vary people are all different
there there is there is no equality
among people
we are all because equality means
sameness we are not the same we are all
different we have different strengths
different weaknesses some of us are
smarter some of us are dumber
some of us are stronger some of us have
more talent you know all these things
vary some of us have more ambition some
of us try harder
and so on and so forth
all right next we have from the ap it
says
pope francis cracked down friday on the
spread of the old latin mass reversing
one of pope benedict's uh the 16th
signature decisions and a major
challenge to traditionalist catholics
who immediately decried it as an attack
on them and the ancient liturgy francis
reimposed restrictions on celebrating
the latin mass that benedict relaxed in
2007 went further to limit its use the
podcast said he was taking action
because benedict's reform had become a
source of division in the church and
been exploited by catholics opposed to
the second vatican council
and now
the new law requires individual bishops
to approve celebrations of the old mass
also called the trinity mass and
requires newly ordained priests to
receive explicit permission to celebrate
it from their bishops in consultation
with the vatican under the new law
bishops must also determine if the
current groups of faithful attach to the
old mass except vatican ii which allowed
for mass to be celebrated in the
vernacular rather than latin these
groups cannot use regular churches for
their services instead bishops must find
an alternate location for them without
creating new parishes so
francis is doing everything he can here
to shut down the latin mass without
saying i'm shutting down the latin mass
he's putting as many hurdles as he can
there were already
plenty of hurdles
um
and now putting many more hurdles some
of them are going to prove to be in many
cases insurmountable and that's the idea
to just shut it down he doesn't want it
now one thing you should know if you
don't follow these kinds of things in
the church because you're not catholic
or even if you are catholic a lot of
catholics don't follow it
to begin with
this almost never happens
where you have one pope
coming immediately after another pope
and so directly contradicting him and
just reversing something that he did one
of one of one of his most signature
moves that he made
um
so that's highly unusual
and meanwhile
as far as the latin mass here's what you
need to know about that
um
you know as a catholic
either kind of mass is legitimate i
don't judge people
whether you go to novus ordo mass which
is the you know the
the normal mass that most people go to
the kite the only kind of mask that pope
francis wants anyone to go to or you go
to the latin mass
you know
one doesn't make you a better catholic
than the other
but
the latin mass
has proven to be deeply appealing
especially to young people
and it's pretty incredible um a lot of
this is anecdotal but i've been to
plenty of of um trinity masses
and i walk in these churches and my
experience almost always is and if you
talk to almost anyone else in any any
other part of the country goes to latin
mass and they'll tell you the same thing
you walk into these churches
which are very conservative
doing this ancient liturgy
in a language that most of people
sitting there don't fully understand
they give you a book though that you can
read to follow along and you learn it as
you go along
um
and you walk in
and so often the place is packed
with young families
little kids young parents
energetic people
by far the youngest and most energetic
parishes i have ever been to
latin
masses it's when you go to the novus
ordo masses and you find
very often these old parishes of you
know average age of 72
and people are sitting there silently
and everyone is bored to death and
there's no energy there's no there's
very few young people very few young
families
you could just you could
you could see the parish going extinct
in front of your eyes
what pope francis is saying is we want
more of that i don't know we don't want
uh last thing we want are parishes that
are young energetic we don't want any of
that
no average age of 72 at the youngest
pope francis is saying
well done
all right um
i wanted to hit this quickly before we
move on to reading the youtube comments
if we have time here i think we do
sharon osbourne we've talked about this
story you may remember what happened to
sharon osborne formerly a co-host of the
show the talk
uh she was forced off the air and
condemned as a racist after an argument
that she had with some other women on
the show who are not white it was an
argument stemming from her defense of
piers morgan who himself was forced off
the air for criticizing meghan markle
uh and sharon osborne all all she said
was that he's not a racist for doing
that and he shouldn't and you know he
shouldn't be canceled
um
this whole issue was brought up to
sharon osborne live on the air
and she claimed at the time and after
that it was a setup that they were
putting her on the spot supposedly
giving her a chance to defend herself
against charges of racism but really
framing her as a racist in the process
because when you when you go on tv and
you're put on the spot
and someone says you're accused of being
a racist care to defend yourself there's
nothing you can say
i mean the only thing you can say is i'm
not going to play that game
but she's not going to say that that's
the correct response is to refuse to
play the game
if you endeavor to actually prove that
you're not a racist all you're doing is
proving that you are a racist
and so she felt that she was set up
the other women on the show have said
that it was not a setup at all and that
this was all her fault two of the other
women involved are cheryl underwood and
elaine welterwroth
and they both after osborne left the
show they threw under the bus they said
publicly that it was not a setup and
that sharon osborne was at fault for all
of this because she refused to listen to
them etc etc and now this from the daily
mail says the talk co-host elaine
welterwroth can be heard consoling a
distraught sharon osborne and telling
her i know you're not racist moments
after the british tv star's heated
on-air confrontation with cheryl
underwood in a newly unearthed audio
recording obtained by the daily mail
well to raw 34 is heard apologizing to
her former coast co-star in reassuring
her that no one thinks she's racist in a
conversation in sharon's dressing room
after the explosive march 10th show so
this was immediately after all that
happened they're in the uh the dressing
room
one of them still has their mic on and
that's how this was caught on uh on tape
and we have a little bit a little clip
of that let's play that
hold on
what exactly are we doing right now help
me understand they asked me to ask that
question i said no i'm not going to
answer
i said wait what's the intention of this
conversation
because this can go left so fast
i'm like they go let me call you back i
said i said to them this is going to be
a train wreck oh look at this sweetheart
he can tell i know
sharon i'm just so sorry that that was
that that went the way that it went do
you know
do you know what it is
when you have to sit there and defend
yourself
it makes you look guilty
because you can't get out of it it's
like jack always says
you can't deny it it's like how do you
at the end of the day
it's like what come look at my web
browser like i'm on a pedophile like you
know it's
all right so it's it's a
there you hear welter off in the
dressing room saying yeah you were set
up i'm sorry it went that way
and then sharon osborne's kicked off the
show and that same woman welteroff uh
goes on the air and throws her to the
bus hey that wasn't a setup
and it's clearly what it was
um
and this this this is what happens i
mean these these are these are these
these snakes just put her in this
position
uh
because because why you know she's an
easy target because she's an older white
woman
and she was the sacrificial goat and
also it was just good publicity and all
the rest of it
and i you almost want to feel sorry for
sherrod osborne
even though you know she's a rich
celebrity she'll be fine
even so for a person to be treated this
way and betrayed in this way of course
if you want to feel some pity you feel
sorry for them and normally i would but
you know what my policy is
i can't feel sorry for you i can't
defend you
um
if you are
you know submitting yourself to this
madness if you go to the altar and you
bow before the altar then there's
nothing i can do
sharon osbourne nothing nothing anyone
could do
sharon osbourne
um prior to all this
according to the daily star reported
daily star she and according to her she
says that she donated seven hundred
thousand dollars to black lives matter
seven
of all the things to donate to seven
hundred thousand dollars
that we know that they didn't they
didn't put any good use at all we know
that for sure
so she goes and um
bows her head
at the blm altar
only to have them chop it off right
there
we've seen this story a million times
people need to wake up
and smarten up all right let's move now
to reading the youtube comments uh
a bunch of comments that are all in a
similar vein
matt should cancel himself for the banjo
trap shameful liar
matt is cancelled for that poor display
of banjo skills
i think we can all cancel matt for not
actually playing the banjo
matt i'm now converting to sour baby
gang after your banjo stunt
and
as i said many comments like that
i'm personally offended by it
i i want it i tried to play it i i
really did
i only had a few minutes
do you want me to start playing the
banjo when it's not properly tuned
and i haven't checked to make sure that
there are no squirrels or anything
hiding inside it these are the basic
things that any badger player does
before playing the banjo i had to run
through all those steps that is proper
banjo etiquette
and then i ran out of time and i
couldn't play it
and then for you to turn around and
attack me in this way
when you know
that there is nothing more important to
me
than the banjo
and my music that i love to play and
absolutely can play
and i wanted to share that with you that
gift
and i wasn't able to think about how bad
i feel about that and now i'm being
attacked
unbelievable
christine says you have always had to
have a license plate on the front of
your car in minnesota as well as the
back it's the law they'll pull you over
anyone for that probably has to do with
the visibility since in the winters here
there is snow caked all over your car
all the time and dirt and salt with two
plates it might increase your odds of at
least being able to see one of them
yeah that is the law with with the
plates of minnesota
and uh that's why that state legislature
was both pulled over
it there there might be a reason for it
i happen to agree i think it's i think
it's ridiculous you know to have a law
where you're now you're pulling people
over
because they have one license plate
instead of two
i think it's absurd i think the police
should be focused on other things
but that's not the cops fault
as we talked about yesterday they are
law enforcement
they're not lawmakers their job is to
enforce the laws that are made
and yes if a law is immoral
if the law is calling them to do
something immoral then they should
refuse to do it even if it costs them
their job
but a lot of these traffic laws they're
not immoral
it's not morally objectionable to have a
law requiring two license plates at one
that is but it's just silly and stupid
um
it's the cops job though to enforce that
so if you don't like that
then you talk to your legislators
about changing the laws
if there is if there is a law
that we would say it's not worth the
cops enforcing it then the law shouldn't
exist
general rule there
and finally tony of scrub nation says my
dream is that matt will read one of my
comments someday
there you go tony
your dream is fulfilled
this is this is the generosity that i
display on this show even as i am
ruthlessly attacked
and yet still
you're welcome
well we're just talking earlier about
the dangerous extremist candace owens
we've got a few dangerous extremists on
the staff here i i like to think that
i'm myself and quite dangerous at least
i try to be uh candace owens certainly
is dangerous with her with her
controversial opinions that might hurt
people's feelings and uh if you have not
had a chance to check out candace owens
well now is your chance to do it just go
to dailywire.com her latest episode cuba
communism and the democratic death cult
is available right now on demand for
daily wire members if you haven't
subscribed yet get 25 off a new
membership with code candace
and also you know as a political
dissident as political dissidents are
thrown onto no-fly lists by the federal
government and children are consistently
being exposed to the left's obsession
with identity in classrooms it's become
incredibly clear
american culture is becoming
authoritarian that's why there's no
better time to learn about what
authoritarianitarianism looks like
even eventually i'll learn how to say it
which will be good too
why it happens and how to stop it it may
sound like a tall order but ben shapiro
explains it all in his new book the
authoritarian moment in it he helps
people understand as much as they can
about how we reach this point and how we
can all begin to fight back so order a
copy of the authoritarian moment today
at amazon or any bookseller let's get
now to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know sometimes i reflect on the fact
that people have been complaining about
political correctness for my entire life
i can remember hearing criticisms of our
pc culture in the 90s and those
criticisms were obviously prescient but
in hindsight
pc culture back then was mere child's
play compared to now
you had to put in some effort to run
afoul of it in those days it took a
little elbow grease you put you had to
be enterprising to earn the label
politically incorrect in the 90s for
example eminem
was politically incorrect but he also
made songs about murdering his own wife
okay
that was politically incorrect
the situation is different now
you can be politically incorrect with a
pronoun
you can be politically incorrect by
reciting basic facts about biology you
can be politically incorrect by saying
something objectionable like um i think
criminals should be arrested or hey
please don't loot my store and burn it
down or sir the men's locker room is
that way or sir that's not where you
work where tampons go
the speech codes aren't just stifling
and oppressive
but but also irrational and morally
ridiculous 25 or 30 years ago a
politically correct person was someone
who was polite
if a bit too sensitive and cautious
now a politically correct person is a
lunatic or at least pretends to be one
we have truly put the political in
politically correct
what is politically correct now is
really only politically correct
ideologically correct in other words it
is in accordance with the prevailing
political and ideological dogmas of our
day it is correct in that sense
but rarely correct in any other sense
and of course these codes invade every
aspect of our lives everywhere we go
including now into the sea
the speech police have decided that they
cannot limit themselves to dry ground
and have now begun instituting speech
codes to govern the aquatic realm as
well so we have two recent examples of
this one is really stupid and the other
is really very extremely profoundly
stupid we'll start with a really stupid
one
nbc news has the story quote minnesota
state senator fung hodge was never a fan
of the asian carp label commonly applied
to four imported fish species that are
wreaking havoc in the u.s heartland
infesting numerous rivers and bearing
down on the great lakes but the last
straw came when an asian business
delegation arriving at the minneapolis
airport encountered a sign reading kill
asian carp
it was a well-intentioned plea to
prevent spread of the invasive fish but
the message was off-putting to the
visitors now some other government
agencies are taking the same step in the
wake of the anti-asian hate crime
epidemic that has a surge through during
the coronavirus pandemic the u.s fish
and wildlife service quietly changed its
designation to invasive carp in april
we wanted to move away from any terms
that cast asian culture and people in a
negative light said charlie woolley
director of its great lakes regional
office the asian carp regional
coordinating committee representing
agencies in the u.s and canada that are
trying to contain the carp will do
likewise on august 2nd he said the move
comes as other wildlife organizations
consider revising names that
some consider offensive including the
intel entomological society of america
which this month dropped gypsy moth and
gypsy ant from its insect list okay by
the way this may shock you but
the reason we call asian carp asian carp
is that asian carp
are from asia
so this was not a conspiracy meant to
encourage anti-asian hate crimes
why is the asian carp designator
necessary well because there are also
other kinds of carbs that originate from
europe do you know what we call the cart
from europe
i'll give you a guess just one that's
right european carp
it's it's a it's pretty common to name
an animal after the place where it lives
originates
it's not entirely clear why an asian
business delegation would be upset by a
sign calling for people to kill asian
carp i mean these business people were
presumably people
if they had any concerns perhaps someone
could have explained to them that they
are people and carp are carp and that
the distinction is rather significant
or maybe here's another possibility
someone in the delegation it's possible
someone in the delegation was named carl
and uh he misread the sign and became
understandably disturbed
i don't know
but as always with these sorts of things
the move is not just pointless and silly
but self-defeating
the goal of wildlife conservationists is
to reduce the population of these fish
because they're screwing up the
ecosystem one way to do that is to
convince people to eat them
that's already a tough sell because all
you have to do is reverse the r and the
a and carp to get an idea of what the
fish tastes like but you're making it
harder on yourself when you call them
invasive carp
i mean asian carp sounds delicious it
sounds delicious it sounds like
something you might get at a chinese
restaurant
invasive carp
sounds like a disease
today our special is invasive carp with
a site of parasitic worms
you know not exactly appealing
so it's a foolish strategy and yet it
seems downright brilliant in comparison
to the next story
going from freshwater to salt water
here's the report from the new york post
it says quote
marine experts and advocates in
australia are urging the public to
refrain from using the word attack in
reference to sharks declaring that the
majestic predatory fish has been
unfairly stigmatized as a deliberate
killer instead officials have suggested
that violent run-ins with sharks be
dubbed with more neutral words such as
interactions
others have suggested swapping the word
with the terms negative encounter
incident or simply bytes bites
shark attack is a lie said university of
sydney language researcher christopher
pepin neff who argued that a majority of
what people call attacks are merely nips
and minor injuries from smaller sharks
government agencies have also begun to
adopt new language including the
department of primary industries in new
south wales which has worked with a
shark survivor support group bite club
to identify more sensitive vocabulary to
describe an audience with a shark
an audience with a shark
that's one way just to describe the plot
of the plot of jaws i guess
but but yes we would want to stigmatize
the poor sharks
who are famous for their emotional
fragility
and we certainly wouldn't want people to
get the wrong idea about the prehistoric
flesh-eating death machines that lurk in
the darkest depths of the sea
i mean when they swim up to greet you on
your surfboard and perhaps nibble on a
few of your appendages no big deal it's
not to be construed as any sort of
attack
so don't be rude about it
try to see this from the shark's
perspective
he came over to make a little small talk
with you maybe grab a quick bite to eat
only to be met with screaming and crying
and the whole production
it's important to remember this also
when you hobble back onto the beach
blood gushing from the spot where your
left leg used to be do not scream out
i've been attacked by a shark
it'd be better and more sensitive to say
i've had an interaction with a member of
the ocean community
then somebody can ask
was it a positive or negative
interaction
and you could say you know i probably
call it negative
all things considered hence the
catastrophic blood loss
i admit i do find it a bit confusing as
to why we need a qualifier like negative
to go along with shark interaction
is there any other kind of shark
interaction
but these questions i suppose are based
in my own deep seated anti-shark bias
the bias that many of us share and which
is only perpetuated by shark attack
victims
who we should not be calling shark
attack victims at all but rather shark
encounter participants
and it's why if you ever find yourself
participating in such an encounter and
you manage to survive it please don't
make a big thing out of it
start whining about your missing limbs
and so forth
think about how the shark feels
i mean you've already ruined his lunch
by escaping
don't add insult to injury here
and so today
after this long and circuitous journey
which has taken us from land to lake to
sea
i think in the end upon further
reflection it must be the shark phobes
who are
in the end
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today and
for the week have a great weekend talk
to you monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin